EA has announced that the March update
for star wars battlefront is out now on
pc ps4 and xbox one the update adds
rebel depot on Tatooine as a new
survival mission and brings survivors of
Endor to the walk result of Supremacy
and turning point modes the next major
expansion for star wars battlefront is
expected to be out to rim which will be
the game's first paid add-on and
features new maps weapons heroes and a
brand new mode outer rim will take place
in the factories on Celeste and Jabba
the Hutt's palace on Tatooine among
other locations the next expansion
doesn't have a release date yet and to
further expansions called Bespin and
Death Star are expected to arrive later
this year uncharted 4 developer Naughty
Dog has responded to some controversy
over the voice actor who plays uncharted
tooth antagonist Harry Flynn as reported
by jewel shockers although Flynn returns
as a multiplayer character and uncharted
for the character is no longer voiced by
the original actor steve valentine
valentine posted a series of tweets
explaining he has not been approached
about uncharted 4 insinuating that there
is a lack of respect for voice actors
from game creators and saying that while
he didn't want to discuss these matters
publicly he believed quote the fans
deserved to know Naughty Dog community
strategist on Maya responded saying that
the developer did in fact contact
Valentine but a deal could not be
reached for him to return his Flynn he
also made it clear that while Naughty
Dog appreciates and feedback they
wouldn't be re-recording any multiplayer
voices before the game's release
uncharted 4 is drew out in May of this
year the division is now out in the
world which means so are the micro
transactions aside from the season pass
there are currently two options on all
platforms a US Marines outfit pack and a
military specialists outfit pack both of
which are priced at five bucks us or
your regional equivalents each contain
four outfits pertaining to their theme
Ubisoft has been pretty tight-lipped
about the nature of microtransactions in
the desert
and have changed their position every
time in 2014 the studio had cooked
definitely planned to allow players to
pay to speed up their progress like in
past you be soft games but by January of
this year creative director Magnus
Jensen confirmed that the idea had been
scrapped and it seems to have stayed
that way for now let me know down in
that comment section how you feel about
cosmetic microtransactions and heard the
games but where we've got news on
valkyria chronicles remastered and a
delay the total war bull hammer that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today bit to pop by same time tomorrow
for a bunch money